James Gunn keeps posting images of DC
Comics characters to social media and he
happens to be someone with a lot of
power to bring those characters to the
big screen what franchise in particular
does he seem to be teasing
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise
director James Gunn really seems to know
his comic book lore after being named
co-leader of DC Studios new film and
television division the director has
been shining a spotlight on some of the
comic Titan's most underused characters
Gunn has recently posted multiple images
from strange Adventures a long-running
DC Comics title that began publishing in
1950 to his social media accounts the
Anthology series which often features
The Adventures of such early DC heroes
as Adam Strange star Hawkins Captain
Comet and the atomic Knights has had
several revivals since its initial
cancellation in 1973. the title returned
for a limited run in 1999 through DC's
vertigo Comics imprint then it came back
in 2004 as JSA strange Adventures which
mainly featured stories involving
members of the Justice Society of
America in 2009 it popped back up as a
six-issue limited series and it returned
once again in 2011 when vertigo
published a one shot under the title the
comic's most recent Revival a 2020
limited series for DC's Black Label
written by Tom King and with art by
Mitch Garretts and Evan Shaner is quite
the serious minded book each issue takes
a harrowing look at Adam Strange and his
fellow members of JSA from the start
strange was a human space adventurer who
was teleported to the planet ran to be
its protector he would periodically
travel back and forth between Rand and
Earth leading a double life
Adam Strange as punctual as ever how
nice of you to drop in
in the 2020 series strange attempts to
take over Earth at the request of the
leaders of the planet picked which is
holding the planet ran and his daughter
Hostage to ensure he holds up his end of
the bargain conflict and confusion ensue
within the JSA guns posts have fans
curious about the director's intent
might there be a film-sized adaptation
of the 2020 strange adventures in the
cards even before Gunn became one of the
Architects of DC's media division he'd
shown an interest in the Publisher's
beloved Legacy titles in September 2022
Gunn tweeted that he'd been reading a
collection of strange Adventures what
seemed like a simple shot of his reading
material soon began to take on a deeper
significance on November 15th Gunn
posted an image of DC's Mr terrific AKA
Michael Holt a brilliant athletic
multi-millionaire who has given a new
purpose in life by joining the superhero
world after a string of private
tragedies to his Twitter the post
immediately sent Comics fans into a
tizzy and sparked debates about who
might play Mr terrific in a movie artist
Mitch Garretts replied the gun's tweet
saying what a strange Adventure this
could be the comic artist's comment came
alongside an image of a glowering Mr
terrific that immediately sparked
speculation that gun's post may be
leading into a big screen version of the
comic series Twitter hasn't been the
only place where gun has been busy he
set up a mastodon account on November
8th and immediately posted a photo of
the space-faring Bounty Hunter and
anti-hero Lobo it appears that gun is
fully dedicated to the unmined potential
of these characters who haven't appeared
in a big budget live-action movie yet I
have all sorts of ideas and we talk
about it all the time audiences will
have to wait and see if guns playful
teases lead anywhere but where there's
smoke there tends to be super powered
fire hopefully strange Adventures fans
will have a movie they can enjoy in due
time
laughs
[Music]